but uh how are you guys in like
surviving japanese summer like how hot
is it today jesus it's like 35 i think
or yesterday was 35. yeah you know what
let me start off with something i hate
it when you can't complain about the
weather where you're from it's like you
know what i i said on twitter i was like
i can't i'm dying man it's 35 degrees
and then someone replies like
it's like 42 here i'm like that is not
something to be proud of you live in a
[ __ ] like the actual sun
bragging i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] like
no matter how hot it is where you are
and you could be [ __ ] dying in the
sahara desert or something you get to
you get to like the nearest town you're
like [ __ ] man i just survived the sahara
and someone from texas or somewhere and
be like oh how hot was it how hot was it
you didn't measure it
no because what i've realized okay i've
i've like living in japan has made me
change my opinion because before what
okay so before moving to japan or before
like moving on totally unrelated
it's not totally unrelated because
before moving to japan or moving out of
england my favorite season was summer
okay yeah i was i was we've discussed
this in the podcast before and we were
like yeah
or maybe it was just off camera i
remember we were like talking about
because i think you and i both like the
winter like much much more winter's
worst season lots of [ __ ] off winter's
worst season maybe this should become a
conversation that we have every single
year the summer turns around and
everyone's like you guys spoke about
this already i'm like it's in my head
shut up no because like i i didn't
realize that uh
it's like summer wind uh summers in
england are actually pretty good and
that's why summer was my favorite season
that doesn't get in england it's like 25
yeah but degrees
the thing right that's the thing no no
it gets hotter than that god that gets
hard to find one there's someone the
summer before we left right yeah but
that one week is pure hell because uk we
don't have air conditioning just doesn't
exist true in homes yeah the one time i
went to the uk it was during that week
it's horrible because yeah you know at
least in japanese summer it's like oh
[ __ ] walking outside [ __ ] this is it
it's way worse but you can just go in
any any building anywhere and you're
like oh cool
they've got yeah they've got the ac
running at full like full blast like
it's good but in the uk
you have no escape in the uk it's like
maybe the gym has ac the supermarket
probably has it but like that's it like
when you go home you're like
put on the tv
cause like what do you do to cool down
in the uk have like nine fans on you so
so you do have fans yeah but the fans
don't do [ __ ] yeah fans don't do [ __ ]
fans are like they're just dissipating
placebos yeah of like you're like yeah
it's definitely doing something you're
like why am i still sweating so much
like it doesn't because all it is is
just taking the stagnant hot air and
just moving it around right yeah
occasionally i just like you go up to it
you know i put my shirt over the fan
yeah i'm like this is true cool that's
that's the best feature
maybe it's a nostalgic thing for me
because growing up or like spending my
summers in thailand uh you know um in
thailand we tried to save costs as much
as possible you know so
like the ac is always like the last
resort that's like when we're literally
like dying of heat stroke yeah any other
time it's just like come on you can
survive with the fan so like i spent
most of my like time and experience
being cooled down by a fan and ac was
just like okay if we don't put the ac on
we're probably going to die here so it's
it's i think that's why it's like kind
of nostalgic for me like like i kind of
like the fan like i kind of like the
feeling
just just on me but i admit like if
you're not used to it like i felt sorry
when you visited yanaki visited us in
the uk because you have to subscribe yes
yes sleep in my room and we that was
like there was one fan in there there
was a single fan in like my entire house
and like joey you can have the fan and i
was like i don't think i actually did
anything for you
i was butt [ __ ] naked in your bed i'm
like i'm still dying it sucks it doesn't
help and it doesn't get cold during the
night the fan yeah i get like the whole
like fan being nostalgic though because
like i have that exact same thing at my
suffering is nostalgic for me
at my grandma's old place in the middle
of nowhere in the mountains yeah we
didn't have ac
it was just because the house was too
big to have a single ac unit yeah yeah
like also all the doors were always open
so it was always with a fan yeah but is
it it's nostalgic
is it good memories though no
i like i like the feeling of like i
prefer the heat the feeling of summer
over winter like any day of the week i
don't know i'm just like i'm just
depressed in winter winter's just like
even even like dying in this heat i
still prefer
what i'm experiencing experiencing now
to winter what what what happens to you
in the wintertime
yeah what happens which is just the
worst scene to [ __ ]
character right what's going on about
this [ __ ] it is it's the worst season
okay okay okay yeah i think it's like
scientifically proven that
people are less people are more happy
with more sunlight right
i think it's literally more healthier
for you to get more sunlight because you
are literally happier
but there is sunlight in the winter
there's like barely any sunlight in the
winter and okay
here's here's the thing that depresses
me the most okay especially if you're
working a nine-to-five job you have to
commute to work you wake up it's you
wake up maybe seven a.m or whatever if
you have to commute long it's like seven
eight a.m you wake up it's dark you go
to the office at nine and it's still
just like the sun's just rising i love
you you stay so fun no because isn't it
great it feels like you beat the morning
yeah that's like yeah
i'm ahead of it you stay inside you stay
inside literally all day you're just in
the office with after artificial light
you go out it's 5 p.m and again it's
dark i like that i like the night how
could
like how can you look how could you not
want any sunshine in your life
you know most of the time i have my
curtains closed yeah i don't know when
it's too hot even in my office now i
have them closed all the time and like
the second thing everything's dead in
the winter there's there's no color at
all you look outside everything's gray
everything's drab how can you be happy
with like zero color i don't know i i
just think you're you're a boring person
like like literally the only thing to
look forward to in winter is christmas
like i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure they invented christmas
because if they didn't have christmas
like everyone would just have nothing to
look forward to objection i'm from
australia we didn't have such things
okay i've never made it to australia
because it's like decent
everyone knows that christmas was
invented by coca-cola
you know i don't know it's it's fun it's
cozy you know you get to it's yeah it's
cozy you get to also you get the most
drip in winter you know like i agree
okay that you get no drip in there i i
wouldn't be wearing this i wouldn't i
wouldn't be wearing this drip in the
winter okay yeah you get the best drip
and you get the best sleep
yeah i'll get this sleep is clean yeah
oh no the sleeves click the window open
a little bit sometimes it's kind of
chilly ooh
it's like you're kind of like it's kind
of like just it's not cold but it's like
a little bit like oh okay maybe i could
you know put something light on but the
moment you hop in that bed and you put
that blanket over you and you're just
wrapped in a warm cocoon there's like
i'm unstoppable this sleep is on my side
now and you just get the best [ __ ]
sleep yeah the mornings suck but yeah
the mornings dude for me all the
mornings suck i can't wake up in the
morning so it doesn't make a [ __ ]
difference to me
okay the only thing i could say i will
say is that i can wear turtlenecks in
the winter exactly
would they be steve jobs without weird
sucks because you you your options are
so limited in the winter it's like i you
can't move sorry the summer you can't
wear more than one layer yeah ever like
a jacket oh well that sucks no i love
jackets jackets are so funny no jesus
hoodies are gone jumpers are gone yeah
gene i wear jeans still now but i'm
dying but that's because i hate shorts
that's but that's why i like british
summers because what i realized that
british summers is just like a
comfortable like it's it's a comfortable
temperature
pre-global warming yes
it was good because you know this this
didn't used to happen i mean it was
never like this in the uk where it was
that bad i remember we always complain
about british summers to be like every
like every british person i've met is
just like oh you haven't experienced
british summer it's like really it's
it's it's rain sometimes it's cold
sometimes and i'm just like it's like it
actually slaps compared to other
substances in other places yeah i would
have agreed with you until like two
years ago when for some reason two years
in a row which had horrible heat waves
that just ruined the summer for me
because it was always fun in the uk the
best part about it is i like it in
summer when the day is hot and the night
gets cool yeah but in japan it doesn't
get cool no it does
no i think it does no compared to like
compared to now like because you know
it's like what [ __ ] 2 p.m right now
it is like the hottest time of the day
right now right yeah yeah but compared
to that euro yeah
but compared to that when it's you know
the sun finally goes down like what like
8 00 pm yeah maybe and like around like
9 or 10 it's like it's pretty
comfortable that's that's the kind of
weather where i'm like okay i'm really
comfortable i can't concentrate with
that guy okay we're gonna cut
but like i like that i like having as
much as i said as much sunlight as
possible and i just i feel like the best
like my favorite time period of the
entire year is about like what's what's
the word like dusk summertime when like
the sun's setting it's about seven eight
pm and you're just watching the sunset
man you feel like a [ __ ] anime
character because it's just like it's
just you know it's it's it's that
[ __ ] scene where you're just like
where the [ __ ] dude in every opening
where like they're the protagonist is
watching the sunset and the wind's just
blowing how often you are you're
standing down
you're [ __ ] bagging being like how
the [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up no it's anime shut the
[ __ ] up
on tatooine right where he's like
watching the sun go down how often how
often are you watching the sunset
honestly that's why i love my balcony
that's why i have a hammock out there
because no no you [ __ ] off you're not
watching the sunset every day i'm not
watching it i'm not watching it every
day but the hottest time of the day in
my opinion because you're getting that
like direct [ __ ] sunlight the hottest
time of the day is [ __ ] now i can't
stand out there it's hot until the sun
goes down
like the moment the sun rises it's the
hottest time of the day
no
no i mean i don't know man i like going
outside and i don't want to have to
[ __ ] you know
shed away my life expectancy to just go
outside yeah i guess that's why for me
in japan i think my favorite season is
probably spring
for me it's the autumn autumn yeah like
around like october it's probably my
favorite time of the year just because
it's like again you have that
you know variance in drip right you can
wear a jacket if it gets a little bit
cold in the night but you can take it
off and you know rock a long sleeve
right but it's also not so cold that
it's excruciating but it's not too hot
either